So it's unit five, lesson one, and we get to talk about miracles.
Now, as you start to prepare for this week, I don't want you necessarily just
thinking about, well, I've got to prove to my students that miracles exist, because
we're going to kind of show a little bit of that.
But more so, that because there are miracles, it points to the
fact that God exists. And we start off, if you just look at what the students are
going in their Bible study, we actually chose 1 Kings 18 for that very reason.
Because when you look at that particular miracle, that miracle of Elijah and the
prophets of Baal and the huge fire that came down and ignited the sacrifice and how
that represented God's sovereign power in that miracle
is just another way we can see that amongst all the things that Jesus did and all
the things in the Bible, this is just a really, really cool example of how God
showed up and performed a miracle so that we can see exactly who God is.
As students are beginning this week and starting to read through, their intro
experience is going to walk them through what kind of, to get them starting to think
about miracles and what that looks like.
So we ask them specifically, like, what's the most improbable event in human
history? Just have them think through, like, gosh, what would be an improbable
event? So things like, it's not likely that if I stepped outside right now, I'd
probably get struck by lightning.
Probably not going to happen. If I was to walk outside with a meteor
just sort of crash down on Earth and annihilate me and everybody around, probably
not going to happen. But is an improbable event the same as
a miracle? So the intro experience for the students is really to get them thinking
through when we talk about a miracle, what are we talking about?
Because you might get some answers.
When you start talking with your students, you might actually get some things like,
well, is it a miracle that when you're out shopping during Christmas season that a
parking spot right by the door opened up?
And is it a miracle and a sign from God that you get this parking?
Maybe, probably not. Is that a miracle, right?
Is it a miracle when a child is born?
We call called the miracle of birth, but is that really a miracle?
We're talking about miracles that we see in scripture.
So that's where you want your students to start to think through and get an idea of
what exactly we're talking about when we're talking about a miracle.
So let's talk for a second about your storyteller.
Now it might have been difficult up to this point, and it may be difficult moving
forward to find the perfect person for your storyteller.
You might have had to search high and low, and maybe this is one of those spots
you're thinking, I really, I don't know exactly who I want for a storyteller.
For this week, I might suggest that you as a student find a student
that maybe has witnessed a miracle, maybe a miraculous healing.
I once had a student that it was hard to refute because she was such a trusted
and honest student, so we knew that she was telling the truth and her experience was
real, but she was on a missions trip in Africa.
And she was praying over a young girl.
And this young girl's legs were not the same somehow.
And she can't explain it and she would tell you today that she has no idea what
exactly happened or how it happened, but she knew some kind of miracle happened.
But as they were praying, it felt to her like this little girl's leg grew
enough that they were the same. And she told me, she's like, Mr.
Kozak, I don't know if this is real.
I don't know if this is true, but I feel like this happened.
And she felt like she was a witness to an actual miracle, a little bit like what
goes on in scripture. Now, none of us were there and none of us can verify it, but
it was a really fascinating story that helps students see the power of a miracle
because what she thought happened, what she saw happen, deeply impacted her.
And today, she still regularly goes to Africa and serves as a missionary there on
and off as much as she possibly can.
That moment deeply impacted her.
And I'm sure it impacted a lot of her fellow students.
So this is one of those times that it might be really cool to find a student that
maybe not that crazy of a story, but a story nonetheless that the student was a
witness to a really divine real miracle so as you get ready
to engage students in sort of a large group time I want you to kind of keep one
thing in mind that the misconception that we've given you that science can explain
away miracles is a very real reality in the life of our students they're taught that
they're conditioned to believe that they're conditioned really for that to be the
default like instead of thinking right away something might be a miracle if you know
they're conditioned to think that right away something just can be explained by
science. And while there should be a healthy balance, because there's a lot of
things that we might think are miracles and end up being able to be explained, but
there's a lot of things that we think we can explain but really end up actually
being a miracle and we really can't explain it as well as we think.
And science doesn't provide that kind of explanation.
Science can't explain the supernatural.
So be aware as you're preparing your lesson to figure out okay, how do I communicate
to students that miracles can actually happen and the difference between
what science can explain and what science cannot explain?
It's going to compel students to start to think about, well, can miracles really
happen today? And maybe more importantly, can miracles happen right here and right
now? See, if you think about it, you're probably going to get some questions, and
this may happen more in your small group time, but you're going
that students will start asking, well, if miracles can happen, how come I don't see
miracles happening in my space and my culture, my sphere of influence and my family
and those kinds of spaces in the same way that we saw miracles in scripture?
I mean, if you just look at the very early stages of Acts and Peter and John walk up
to the temple and there's a lame guy sitting in front of the temple.
He can't walk. He's never been able to walk.
And the Bible tells the story of Peter simply reaching his hand out saying, I don't
have any money, but what I have I give you in the name of Jesus.
Get up and walk. And the guy gets up and walks and he's instantaneously healed.
And what's fascinating about that story is that this guy has never been able to walk
since birth. Complete muscle atrophy in his legs.
And all of a sudden his ankles become strong and he's jumping up and down.
He's walking. So students are going to ask the question, well, how come those
miracles don't happen here today?
Well, they might not happen in your city all that frequently, if ever.
They might not happen in this country all that often or that frequently or whatever.
But we don't know that they don't happen.
They might. And it's likely that they do happen.
Maybe not to that degree. I don't know.
But we can't discount the fact that they just don't happen.
We can't say they just don't happen.
They might happen. And God has the power to make that happen if he so chooses.
So miracles of a biblical proportion, I would argue, are still possible.
So while students are in small groups, encourage your small group leaders to really
take time this week to ask, maybe pry a little bit your students to see, are
they really convinced? And convinced of a couple of things.
First, are they convinced that miracles are even possible at all?
Is that even a possibility? And take note of that.
Have your small group leaders actually take note of that because that's going to
become important next week when we start talking about the resurrection of Jesus.
Are your students convinced that miracles are at least possible?
Number two, are your students convinced that miracles have happened in their midst,
whether by their friends or by people that they know or have they read things?
Are they convinced that miracles have actually happened?
So yes, the first they have to be convinced that they're possible in order to be
convinced that they've happened.
But walk them through that process.
And then ask them if they're not convinced, what would it take?
What would it take to help them see the probability and the possibility of miracles
all around them? Do they have to open up their view of God?
Do they have to just open up their view of who Jesus is and what the cross is all
about? We'll get to that next week.
What has to happen for them, do they think, in order to make miracles a reality
in their mind so that they can at least see some of the things that God is up to?
One thing to keep in mind as you're navigating through this, although we talk a lot
about the fact that miracles are possible and they're verifiable and that they do
happen, and we see throughout Scripture that God works in mighty ways and we want to
boast that miracles happen all throughout the world.
But this can also be a very, very personal thing.
Miracles can bring up really, really important questions in the lives of our
students.
How come God performed a miracle in this person's life but not in my life?
How come God healed this person but not this person?
It almost feels like God is picking and choosing.
How does that work, and how do you walk with students through
difficult times like that? And I'm going to be honest with you.
There's really not a specific answer that I can give you that, well, God does this
because it's not there. But your job as a leader is to walk alongside
and help your students in their specific situations navigate those particular
circumstances and those particular parts of their lives so that they grow closer
to Christ, not further.